Tucker Carlson drops bombshell revealing
what got him fired with Fox News uh
let's see what the reason is for him
getting fired so T Caron former Fox News
host uh discuss his departure from the
network stating I didn't expect to get
you know my show cancelled Mond morning
expressing his lack of surprise but not
providing specific reasons for the
firing he added they were very nice to
me the entire time I was there but I
could feel that they strongly disagreed
in the war in Ukraine stuff they really
didn't like at all the January 6 Steph
Carlson also hinted at unpredictably of
the upcoming 2024 presidential election
noting that it might not be a con
contest between Joe Biden and Donald
Trump due to establishment's actions and
Biden's declining popularity in the poll
saying this is not going to be a race
between Joe Biden and Trump and by the
way Rob right before this gave me some
news Rob did you did you see that story
with
uh now they're going after Justin Wills
uh his business partner according to
Wall Street Journal Tucker Carlson's
longtime producer is accused of sexual
assault in suit former Fox News staffer
said Justin Wells forcibly kissed him
and grabbed his grabbed his genitals
what in late 2008 Wells denied the Alle
so I had I didn't even know he was gay
man on man stuff wa who who is this guy
so he the toer talk Justin wells in a
lawsuit from former Fox News Dan Justin
WS invited him to go come to his barment
before they were joined other people at
near by bar the alleged incident took
place in 2000 shortly after enjoying the
Stu the suit set so after serving him a
drink Wells pushed n to his bed forcibly
kissed him and grabbed his genital the
Alle Legend full lawsuit which was filed
in New York Monday here we go again that
sounds like a night Adam that's a
Thursday night for if that's a guy doing
it to another guy that's just classic
locker room talky like slaps my ass
every time I see every single time hey
tip God nut Shack that's how we roll bro
that's let me ask you question let me
ask you a question how much of
this how much of this do you think it's
you know Fox finding ways to get back at
Tucker and how much it is you think it's
real what do what do you think is it's
all going after tuck It's a combination
anything to discredit him because yeah
go ahead I think it's a combination of
number
one they were on the clock because they
had to get these suits filed and number
two I think fox look do they leak things
about their talent when they're
negotiating new contracts they to do
they leak things about their talent when
they leave and go to another place well
he was a handful to work with and the
ratings were slipping according to ourl
analysis when someone leaves and goes
from it's remember Katie krik left and
she went to Yahoo and all of a sudden
NBC was like well it all wasn't what you
really think it was and they leak those
things out do they do that yes they do
so is Fox leaking right now yes but is
there already these um um Adam what is a
deadline there was a deadline a week ago
for the harassment suits you could go
back could go back 25 years why do you
think I know that date yeah no no you're
right Tom you're actually you're
absolutely right it was like a I forgot
the name of it but they around the I was
just going to ask you that question
sexual assault well I was going to go to
Wikipedia or you so I went to you so
yeah this is what it's called right here
that's why that's why did he is the
complaint said it fell under the adult
Survivor act a law that passed in New
York's Democratic leg legislature and
took effect on Thanksgiving last year
that law opened a year-long window
during which people who say they were
sexually assaulted as adults could sue
their alleged abusers regardless of when
the alleged abuse
occurred Bu from the 80s and I think Fox
absolutely said hey that guy's filing a
suit and then they throw a leak out to
page sex well and dude but and look how
easy this is I know you were joking Adam
you know how easy it is to do the sexual
assult like ready for this Adam
yesterday in the in the break room you
grab my crotch that's it it's a story
it's out I feel anything Vin but that's
whatever you know why because I was in a
sauna I hate when he brings it up but
but but B all it is is an accusation and
by the way there's no cameras in there
you talk prove me wrong but now it's in
the news it's you have to get a lawyer
and then it's and now people think you
back to the actual Tucker situation
right because we're talking about his
producers we're talking about whoever
the guy was yeah back to the Tucker
situation this article which is
basically from what the daily fetched
whatever this which one are you talking
about the what the one you just read
Tucker no the one I
talked the the Justin Wells is from Wall
Street Journal no no not that one this
yes it is regardless the real reason
that regard me go ahead what were you
going to say go just hit this nail on
the head Adam if you're going to do
Jesus but the point is what this article
leaves out are two major names they
don't talk about the murdocks Y and they
don't talk about Roger alses and they
certainly don't talk about Dominion to
me that's the three biggest reasons that
Tucker got fired they're sort of
subjugating it with this uh Ukraine
stuff January 6 whatever Roger ales died
the murdocks and the Murdo kids took
over this Dominion what was it $1.8
billion doll lawsuit what was it maybe
even more big whatever the hell it was
and I assume part of the lawsuit was
they needed a head to roll and who's a
bigger head literally Fox News nailing
him in the head right
there than Tucker Carlson so that's to
me the reason that he basically left if
the murdocks wanted Tucker there he
would still be there they didn't choose
a good enemy pack cuz he chose his enemy
if you think about it he chose them and
he went I hit that nail on the head
speaking of I mean not not to be the B
hey Vinnie not to cut you off but go
ahead
Tom Right Tom goad your Point's more
important um and what bugs me about this
story is repeatedly grabbed repeatedly
grabbed his apartment if you're going to
grab it Tom you're going to go for hang
on at his apartment at his apartment
drop it so number one you're at the
apartment number two after after after a
grab you'd be like dude you're drunk get
away from me and and then a second
attempt don't you leave but you're
hanging around for repeatedly grab it's
like the old it's it's it's it's like
you're hanging around for another grab
that's right you're playing grab ass
it's like the old money python film that
goes you were raped and he says well at
first it started by the way you know it
it I I I've spoken to Justin before he's
very respectful when he and I my
experience with him has been great but
this is even a bigger thing to show that
Tucker no matter what his position is
his main executive his main producer is
gay and Tucker never talked about it he
didn't use that adverti it anything and
we find out in a situation like this if
it wasn't for the grabbing we would have
never known okay nobody cares by way
everything in this story is allegedly we
don't know who's grabbing or touching
playing grab us other than me grabbing
Vinnie in the break room I am a little
bit uncomfortable when these stories
come out like this yeah whenever it
comes out like this kind of pump the
brakes and put a little bit of the
paranoid hat on and see what's going on
so so if you like this clip and you want
to watch another one click right here
and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here